i
[Música]
a
francia se está enfrentando a una
segunda ola de la epidemia de
coronavirus de hecho tanto parís como
tres de los departamentos que la rodean
pasaron en alerta máxima y esto quiere
decir que durante los próximos 15 días
hay nuevas restricciones una de ellas el
cierre de cafés y de bares de piscinas
de gimnasios de hecho para visitar a las
personas en residencias de adultos
mayores hay que hacerlo solamente con
cita previa y las universidades tienen
que disminuir su aforo al 50% de su
capacidad se ha pedido también a las
personas que privilegian el teletrabajo
el trabajo a distancia los restaurantes
por ahora mantienen las puertas abiertas
pero cumpliendo con un protocolo
sanitario mucho más estricto una de las
medidas por ejemplo es que los
comensales tienen que mantener puesta la
mascarilla en todo momento y solamente
pueden quitársela cuando vayan a
consumir el gobierno ha cambiado su
manera de manejar a la epidemia como lo
hizo durante la primavera ya no se trata
sólo de tomarán medidas que tengan un
impacto a nivel nacional sino también de
permitir a las autoridades locales de
adaptar las medidas a sus territorios
pero todo esto claro con el aval del
gobierno central
[Música]
alrededor de 30 municipios españoles se
encuentran cerrados perimetralmente
municipios en los que en total vive
menos de un millón de personas personas
por lo tanto que no pueden entrar ni
salir de sus localidades si no es por
razones laborales u otros motivos de
fuerza mayor sin embargo la noticia
destacada de las últimas horas es el
levantamiento del cierre perimetral
tanto de aquí de la capital como de
otras nueve ciudades de la comunidad de
madrid' que se encontraban cerradas
desde el pasado viernes 2 de octubre y
es que el tribunal superior de justicia
de madrid acaba de emitir una sentencia
en la que indica que esta medida
vulnera directamente los derechos
fundamentales y las libertades
individuales de la población sin que
haya detrás un marco legal validado y
habilitado por las cortes generales que
así lo permita pero recordemos que este
mismo tribunal sí que válido una orden
dictada directamente por la comunidad de
madrid' que estableció a finales de
septiembre el cierre perimetral de
ciertas zonas sanitarias sobre todo del
sur de la ciudad en las que precisamente
vive sobre todo clase trabajadora que
necesita desplazarse cada día por
motivos laborales a otros
de la capital
[Música]
frente al temor de una segunda ola
epidémica italia endurece las medidas
para combatir el coronavirus el gobierno
impuesto el uso de tapabocas obligatorio
en los lugares cerrados las oficinas las
fábricas los comercios pero también al
aire libre en el exterior si se está al
contacto de otras personas el estado de
emergencia ha sido prorrogado hasta el
31 de enero del año próximo ya que con
la llegada del invierno se prevé que la
situación pueda empeorar una situación
que desde ya preocupa las autoridades
italianas que en las últimas semanas han
visto una lenta y progresiva degradación
de la situación con un aumento de los
contagios que aunque son inferiores a
los de países como francia y españa-
pues están llegando a niveles
inquietantes y las autoridades
sanitarias italianas prevé en meses
difíciles de convivencia con el
coronavirus aquí en italia
[Música]